Smile!
For even in elimination
you have become children of Brady!
We have a 25-point lead.
Huh, I feel like people are
never going to let me get over this.
One more
and I’ll have just as many as the Steelers!
Thomas is coming.
You all in the AFC need to stop him.
If he wins again
it will be boring on a scale
this league has never seen.
Prepare the offense
engage all defenses
and get this man a coach
who can maximize his serviceable talent!
Hey, I’m a computer man.
Something’s wrong.
St. Louis is deserted.
All that’s left is baseball
and a Six Flags.
STAN KROENKE?!
WE HAD TO LEAVE ST. LOUIS!
IT’S A SMALL MARKET TOWN!
I need you to pay me.
It’s the only way to stop Brady.
It can’t be done!
You play defense!
RPO.
Is he OK?
OH, THAT’S JUST COACH
TRYING TO GAME PLAN.
Fun teams in the AFC?
I will restore order to the universe.
I’M GOING TO TAKE DOWN THE GOAT!
It’s working!
I see so many articles about how this
could be the end of the Patriots dynasty.
AH, FUDGING BRADY
STOPPING ME FROM BEING A G.D. H.O.F.-ER.
CALM DOWN, PHIL!
FUDGE.
In my experience
giving him back the ball is bad.
Jeez, we get it.
Oh hey, look—I got us to overtime!
Overtime rules.
Tom gets to punch first.
If he misses, Patrick gets to punch.
WAIT, I MIGHT NOT GET TO PLAY?!?!
Great competitor. Hell of a game.
We’re at the end of the game now!
The Rams are our last chance.
Me and the Rams had a bit of a falling out...
NO, I SHOULD WIN.
Oh, sorry! I didn’t see that.
STOP HOLDING OUT!
YOU’RE HURTING YOURSELF!
AHHHHHHHHH!
OK, Todd
now may be a good time to unleash
THE GURLEY!
AHHHHHHHHH!
Yo, something weird
is going on with me right now.
What are they?
White no-name position players.
Totally expendable.
ATTACK!
THIS OLD THING STILL WORKS!
HALLE BERRY!
I don’t even know who you are.
Jared’s a system quarterback
JUST LIKE YOU!
NOT TRUE!
You shouldn’t have gone for my head.
No!
Roughing the passer!
Oh fun!
A new setback!
I am Lamar!
I am…
AH, FLUFF-
Hell yeah, I get to disappear again!
MR. BREES
I DON’T FEEL SO GOOD.
I blame the refs
and I refuse to accept this reality.
OK, so that’s one of the 14 million ways
this could go down.
Let’s practice it again!
Ugh.
Thanos didn’t go far enough.